welcome to this video playing Michael H
Michael Hennigan as the name I guess
yeah he doesn't have a name in there but
that's true he's got the grease for like
as he joined the ranks of Nigel short
being an olive farmer and near Athens
okay yeah Greek olive oil is so
excellent really i only use that the tab
royal let's see not Nigel shots this
would be fun right importing olive oil
from Nigel short maybe I should check if
he is selling it directly would be fine
okay we have the Kings Indian market
gone of variation very young come and
guest in my my games let's see it's one
of the lines where an early age six
husband plate which limits blacks
options in some lines and some in some
cases here here there is such a case in
some cases white can take on c5 and take
on a form and this is not a good idea
with the porn on h7s then bishop age six
becomes an idea however here if i take
take night a for there is probably see
takes d5 and this is not really looking
too promising okay but it's not
necessary I can play h5 as well
just the normal advance here okay hmm
that's interesting no no 94 is threaded
at a three is threatened that's that's
not good h5 wasn't well timed
wow that's that's really annoying that
very annoying and I cannot protect you
forward the Queen due to g4 hanging
oh I don't really have a move here there
is no no good move
yeah a 3m just a 3 and black ass better
cannot even nite b3 is got queen before
him
why is he not playing yeah why is he not
playing that it's a just obviously the
right move yeah maybe I can try this but
it's not looking good ready
is their queen before ba3 Quincy 3-inch
a capacity to try to to trap the Queen
oh it took them and that that is
surprising I thought that this might
still be okay not sure but yeah there's
still the spinning situation of course
but I thought maybe Quincy one is still
move that can be played he just takes me
three of course okay so Quincy to take
stakes on this beautiful but okay it
could have could have been worse i guess
could have been worse
I mean I'm not enthusiastic about my
child to see her but it felt it felt
like I was it what could have been even
even more tricky came see porn you know
taking with the sea pony as rook c8
coming I know probably for something oh
yeah that's really terrible what the
terrible game Pia this looks like
disaster will strike him
oh yeah it was that was really bad and
it feels like a bit of a DJ booth
situation I think I had this before the
Sun check for the some um this idea with
Queen a5h five was really really bad I
came so is there some way to muddy the
water here
I the c4s hanging all the time the same
as possible I have 92 but ok it's still
winning
I'm just g5 I have no particular idea
with that I was just trying to try to
confuse them in a way time warning
yeah I think I mean probably a lots of
moves are Winningham g5 even i am not
even sure that this is any good in
comparison 94 maybe is this possible i
can take you can just take everything
night if one takes on each floor
it's got Queen f5 I know but
the Queen trade is probably the easiest
winning on time but there are many moves
that win check so what is this two pawns
down young it's just a bit surprising
not sure but what this was all about
check maybe it was just good but I
didn't I didn't didn't see that white
resigns well I simply I simply played h5
too quickly this wasn't what to quickly
add it took some time but as it I just I
just didn't think about Queenie 5g files
but I h5 as possible but they eat age 5
is just not good after that I mean maybe
something else but here I'm just I'm
just worse we are Queen before was quite
obviously better when she didn't play
and not quite sure why but okay this
this is probably I don't know it's so
terrible check
it's probably just that young I mean
this is just just not working at all
right here there are many many
aggressive things probably working yeah
h5 is just a better bad move in this
opening I should probably just go gt5
here and try to try to play this
position Knight f3 am not sure a very
calm calm complicated I is chatting here
Butchie one yeah this is also possible
just just keeping g5 and now probably a
3m I need to address this idea yeah this
is a complicated position that it's not
easy to assess I mean now be five and
probably I need to they are before us
coming never Enders I've goodnight see
form so yeah and create rights now now i
agree basically all right thanks for
watching